a regà buongiorno buongiorno a tut arca
vacca speca un senso al e questa è una
bella vista questo è busto arsizio
come potete vedere questa busto arsizio
la c'è il sindaco di busto minion
comunque è veramente figo sto posto
questa è la pista del mio hotel è
gigantesca wat pho e come potete vedere
lì c'è poco art e questo sono io lo so
che sono un grafico adesso non basta i
commenti lo sposo ragazzi non c'è
bisogno
qual è la pochette che ho fregato
dall'aereo perché è più bella più
elegante della mia che brutta in
troviamo agli universal studios tra
trovo già molto umido gli universal
studios sono passati quattro anni hanno
fatto un miliardo di fi nuovi oggi sono
tornati agli universal studios perché
tappa fissa a los angeles soprattutto
hanno aggiunto attrazione di roba di
strange things e hanno messo howard si
divide in diverse parti questo parco a
tema
credo sia un parco a tema che questa
parte dove si comprano le cose le
schifezze da portare ai parenti e di qua
ci sono tutte le attrazioni che ci vai
con con gli amici vero amici
ma è che marco va ok fetta ciclo degli
altri
[Applauso]
no ok io volevo fare degli amici
la fai una foto a me mio zio quanto sei
bella devo venire da vicino a vedere
cosa click ogni clic sami pose click
click
in avanti invece il cadere all'indietro
fare le news ma non lo faccio
horror trip secondo te di questo trip
cosa c'è di horror il prezzo 299 dollari
mi compro daniel radcliffe
signori questa è l'entrata del universal
studios hollywood
sapete qual è la cosa molto più
cinematografica di tutto questo il
biglietto costa 130 si paga allora
siccome siamo entrati abbiamo soltanto
due ore e ac comandare direttamente alla
trazione di harry potter visto che
abbiamo solo due ore e rischiamo pure di
non farla veniamo da harry potter e
vediamo
non pensavo di poter vivere così tanto
da vedere una scena del genere
prezzo socute
[Musica]
allora dopo sei ore di camminata siamo
arrivati a hotmail e california c'è la
neve sui tetti e versi e ma perché
magica zio
adesso vi facciamo fare un tour di porto
con me va bene dimmi se non è il a lui e
massimo 2 massimo ciao massimo
sono felice come un bambino che voleva è
fatta benissimo e querce la burrobirra a
fred e george weasley e buono qui sono
qui non ho neanche nello stomaco cauto
perché anch'io ti guardo giù di tono di
leader stiamo entrando si contrae con la
burrobirra si va bene ma sono tutti i
magici qua posti magici dove poi entrare
la burrobirra c'è la casa di hagrid sto
male sto non è bellissimo bellissimo
sono un bambino su un bambino c'è la
moto di hagrid zio ma tu non capisci
niente ma tieni qua di più nella vita
serve un impatto che voglio bene anch'io
li si entri solo se sei amico di hagrid
bedin anche lui amico di hagrid
simpatico non puoi essere tu cosa vuoi e
quindi davanti nel suo allora capisci a
me frate stiamo per volare occupato ma
dopo devo fare la foto copertina 0 foto
libertina beh mi hanno rotto le balle
per non registrare durante la
la corsa ma è durata qualcosa come 8
secondi quindi non è che vi siete persi
tante realtà non c'era niente affatto
sto giro strano e c'era guazzo molto
figo
[Musica]
ecco quando uno e fans e scavalca i
cancelli ce l'hai biglietto certi date
incredibile e bellissimo addirittura
bella cosa prima e riporta come contento
provi j
la bacchetta scegliere mago hai
parcheggiato la macchina franco personam
e se ne vanno loro è buio pesto non è
derrick cosa andremo a trovare o mio dio
tu non lo sai ma questa protesta
sottofondo del film oh mio dio no ha
scritto dio non ci credono il ciclo sto
male voi lo sapete la frase per salire
no no era sorbetto al limone prova
benissimo i quadri si muovono sto male
malaga non ci credo si muovono i quadri
ma date pazzesco
poi loro incredibile
e incredibile è fatto troppo bene questa
è la signora grassa
si chiama veramente così stiamo uscendo
dalla zona di harry potter ci sono state
due attrazioni l'ultima attrazione che
abbiamo fatto non l'ho registrata perché
era una trazione in realtà virtuale non
si vedeva niente tra la sua videocamera
sono cagato addosso perché la scelta
sono spuntati i ragni però è stato
veramente figo veramente tissimo non
avevamo visto ma c'è negozio di dolci
let's go in sto male ragazzi e non i
dolci e veramente fatto bene ma
veramente di fare shopping nel film di
harry potter sto malissimo comprerei
tutto io comunque con tra tutte le cose
comprerei il cane ragazzi ho trovato la
roba della vita della vita il filtro
d'amore
lo sai che cos'è questo no ma stammi
lontano
è esattamente quello che pensi siamo
usciti raga e siamo pensa nel mondo dei
synth anche quadro bloggato tipo quattro
anni fa ti ricordi ce crasti don't get
open inside ok e quindi ragazzi questo
era il nostro questo è stato il nostro
trip agli universal studios nel 2018
sono passati tre anni adulti natale ho
fatto è stato molto figo non ho potuto
registrare alcune cose che ho fatto
purtroppo perché mi cazziava non avevo
il telefono e regista vero nonostante
questo avete visto un sacco di roba
spero che vi sia piaciuto anche lui ha
visto il video è contento se mi è
piaciuto 16 al momento mi piace anche
per i soci ha guidato dalla descrizione
sono state fischiate non ci vediamo
ragazzi o bella ciao a tutti i cavoli
esattamente
[Musica]